>>It's three PM in
Chicago and schools
around the city are
winding down for the day.
But in a renovated downtown
warehouse, a program called
After School Matters
is in full swing.
[singing] Two, two, two, three.
>>The program, which today
serves over 25,000 teens,
started as a summer arts
program in a vacant lot.
>>This is lot thirty seven.
It was an empty lot in
the middle of the city.
Every kind of art that you can think
of took place here on
this wonderful block.
Therefore, we called the
program Gallery Thirty Seven.
>>Narrator: Gallery Thirty Seven,
which offers programs in the visual,
performing, culinary
and theater arts,
has branched out to
include Words Thirty Seven,
promoting literacy skills like
journalism and creative writing.
>>Where the city belongs
to the adolescent.
>>Narrator: Tech Thirty
Seven, offering web design,
video production and robotics.
Sports Thirty Seven, for
health and fitness programs.
And recently, Science Thirty Seven,
all under the umbrella
of After School Matters.
>>To keep our students interested
in school, to keep them motivated,
we have to help every single
child find their unique skill,
their unique interest.
So may it's dance or
drama or computers,
or working with other students
and teaching and coaching.
And After School Matters has
provided that so that many,
that portfolio of options.
Every student's not gonna
want to go to school frankly
because they love biology
or love trigonometry.
But it might be for that
after school program.
>>So you just pat these dry,
but don't press too hard,
because if you do, they'll break.
>>If a young person's in our program,
they are less likely to be truant.
They have fewer course failures.
Perhaps if they're not having a great
success story in the school day,
they get success in the after school
program that reinvigorates them,
helps raise their self esteem
and helps them feel good
about themselves, so they
show up that next day
for school, ready to learn.
>>Narrator: The students
who participate
in After School Matters receive
modest stipends for working
as apprentices with professionals.
>>It's awesome.
Like the teachers were
great and it's really fun.
It's just like a class but we get
paid for it, so that's the part.
>>Our model of an apprenticeship
program lends authenticity
and real world expertise that
could help them to light a spark
about what they may want to study, or
careers that they may wanna explore.
>>Let's do the dance motion again.
I wanna make sure that
everybody has that motion down.
One, two, a five, six, seven.
>>You got it.
Two, then three, four.
>>These are not teachers.
These are people who are
professionals in their field
and what they bring is just
this passion that they have.
"I love this work and I
wanna tell you about it
and I wanna show you how I do it."
>>All: [singing] "Let's
go to the hop."
>>After School Matters partners
with community organizations
to leverage existing resources.
They also raise private
funds so teens from all
across the city can
access their programs.
>>Some of these youngsters lived in
public housing and some of them lived
in the Gold Coast and we
brought them together.
And you know what, they
learned to like one another
and to trust one another
and to realize
that they had far more
similarities than dissimilarities.
I think that's a gift
to give a young person.
These young people have so
much to offer and all we need
to do is give them that opportunity.
It's really very simple.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org